everyone keeps asking what's going on
with bitcoin well let's go talk to the
institutions the director of global
macro at fidelity jordan timmer he came
out with a fire thread explaining
exactly how they think of bitcoin right
now let's jump right into it first he
said is bitcoin cheaper than it looks
well if we consider a simple pe metric
for bitcoin to be the price network
ratio then that ratio is back to 2017
and 2013 levels even though bitcoin
itself is only back to late 2020 levels
valuation often is more important than
price and that's what we've been talking
about for a couple of days now is the
valuation is different than price the
price is what you pay the value is what
you get then if we look at the second
tweet here we can see another way to
highlight this is by overlaying
bitcoin's non-zero addresses against its
price price is now below the network
curve insinuating that the price is
lower than the actual value of the asset
that you're getting and then last but
not least timber follows it up and he
says in his third tweet that the next
chart shows how technically oversold
bitcoin is glass node's dormancy flow
indicator is now to levels not seen
since
2011. again no one knows what's going to
happen in the future but what we do know
is that historically if you buy assets
for less than they are actually worth if
you buy the price lower than the value
that tends to be a great strategy this
is a timeless investing principle one
that has been popularized by warren
buffett charlie munger and many many
other investors regardless of how you
analyze bitcoin there are multiple
metrics they are flashing red and they
are showing that bitcoin's current price
is lower than these various value
metrics now of course there's always
risk and people have to ask themselves
how will bitcoin perform in the macro
environment the fed's in control all
assets are correlating towards one and
it seems like it's one big trade but
over a long enough time period if
bitcoin is able to survive which i think
it will then of course bitcoin will end
up at some point being valued more
fairly and so ultimately as price falls
keep looking at the value obviously
jiren timur the director of global macro
over at fidelity he thinks that bitcoin
is undervalued right now and i tend to
agree hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time